Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Pedro Rodriguez Filou, or Pedrino as he came to be called, was born on June 17, 1954. He had a misshapen skull due to a deliberate kick his mother, Manuela, had received to her pregnant belly from her husband, Pedro Rodriguez Sr. Given the level of violence their father inflicted upon their mother, Pedrino and his
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。佩德罗·罗德里格斯·菲卢（Pedro Rodriguez Filou），后来被称为佩德里诺（Pedrino），于1954年6月17日出生。他的头骨畸形，这是因为他的母亲曼努埃拉（Manuela）怀孕时，肚子遭到她丈夫老佩德罗·罗德里格斯（Pedro Rodriguez Sr.）的一记故意踢击。考虑到他们父亲对母亲施暴的程度，佩德里诺和他的
seven younger siblings were lucky to be born at all. The Rodriguez children grew up on a farm in the Brazilian municipality of Santa Rita do Subacai, south of the state of Minas Gerais. Although the family was poor, they did not experience the extreme poverty that afflicted much of rural Brazil during the 1950s and 60s, at which time impoverished citizens were often viewed as disposable. Crime was commonplace, clean water was mostly diverted for crops, and a lack of sanitation led to diseases for which there was no money to treat. A common saying in the area was that God must exist, because the devil certainly did.
七个弟妹能生下来实属幸运。罗德里格斯的孩子们在巴西米纳斯吉拉斯州南部圣丽塔-杜苏巴凯（Santa Rita do Subacai）市的一个农场长大。尽管家里很穷，但他们并没有经历20世纪50和60年代困扰巴西大部分农村地区的极端贫困，当时贫困的公民往往被视为可以随意丢弃的人。犯罪司空见惯，干净的水大多被分流用于灌溉农作物，缺乏卫生设施导致了无钱治疗的疾病。当地有一句俗话：上帝一定存在，因为魔鬼肯定存在。
Pedro Sr. worked hard for a meager salary as a night security guard at a local school, and was considered an agreeable man until he drank alcohol, which brought out his violent temper. Manuela was a religious disciplinarian who was quick to punish her children and unafraid to administer beatings. Her eldest, Pedrino, would often accompany her to church, but he never understood what the pastor was saying and would sometimes fall asleep, earning him a thrashing. Pedrino's grandfather, Joaquim, whom Pedrino described as a simple gentleman, became his mentor, teaching him skills he needed in order to survive, including how to swim, plant, harvest, hunt, and defend himself.
老佩德罗在当地一所学校当夜间保安，微薄的薪水全靠辛苦劳作换来。在喝酒之前，他被认为是一个随和的人，但酒精会激发出他暴戾的脾性。曼努埃拉是一个笃信宗教的严厉管教者，她惩罚孩子毫不手软，也从不畏惧拳打脚踢。她的长子佩德里诺经常陪她去教堂，但他从来听不懂牧师在说些什么，有时还会睡着，这常常给他招来一顿痛打。佩德里诺的祖父华金（Joaquim）被佩德里诺描述为一个朴实的绅士，他成了佩德里诺的导师，教导他生存所需的技能，包括游泳、种植、收获、打猎和防身。
Joaquim took Pedrino to his job at the butchery and taught him how to carve up an ox carcass, which served Pedrino well when he later started work at a chicken slaughterhouse. Joaquim coached Pedrino to become a, quote, worthy, correct, and just man. He grew into a tough teenager, and although he was smaller than most boys his age, he was determined and fearless. Pedrino's most defining characteristic was his deep resentment of injustice. In 1967, Pedrino was 13 years old and violence was a part of his daily life. He saw it at home, in the streets, and at his work, where animals were slaughtered without any regard to humane
华金带着佩德里诺去他的肉铺工作，教他如何分割牛尸，这为佩德里诺后来去鸡肉屠宰场工作打下了良好的基础。华金指导佩德里诺成为一个——引述——有价值、正直且公正的人。他成长为一个坚强的少年，尽管他比同龄的大多数男孩都要矮小，但他意志坚定、无所畏惧。佩德里诺最显著的特征是对不公的刻骨仇恨。1967年，佩德里诺13岁，暴力成了他日常生活的一部分。他在家里、街上以及工作场所都见证了暴力，那里的动物被屠宰时完全不考虑人道主义
practices. On one occasion, he took his cousin's horse for a ride without asking, and in return, received a forceful punch to the face. Shocked, Pedrino looked directly at his much older and larger cousin and said, I'm going to kill you. His cousin laughed and hit him again. Other family members who heard about the altercation laughed at Pedrino for being weak. Over the following weeks, he found himself consumed by feelings of revenge and injustice. Pedrino's grandfather worked at the local sugarcane mill, and one day, Pedrino and his cousin were assisting him.
做法。有一次，他没经允许就骑着表哥的马出去兜风，结果脸上挨了重重的一拳。震惊之余，佩德里诺直视着比他大得多也壮得多的表哥说：“我要杀了你。”表哥笑了笑，又打了他一下。其他听说这场冲突的家庭成员都嘲笑佩德里诺软弱。在接下来的几周里，他发现自己被复仇和不公的情绪吞噬了。佩德里诺的祖父在当地的甘蔗磨坊工作，有一天，佩德里诺和他的表哥正在帮他的忙。
The two were responsible for feeding the sugarcane through the press, a machine consisting of two rollers that crushed the brown juice out of the stalks. Pedrino waited for the right moment before calmly shoving his cousin into the press, pushing him with all his might in an effort to force his body through the rollers. His cousin's arm was mangled up to his shoulder, but the rest of his body jammed up against the machine. Pedrino tried pushing his cousin's head into the rollers, but it was the wrong size and shape, causing the rollers to spin against it without grabbing hold. Pedrino then grabbed a pair of pruning shears and began stabbing his cousin, hoping to cut him up enough to force him
两人负责把甘蔗喂进压榨机，这台机器由两个滚轮组成，能把甘蔗茎里的棕色汁液挤压出来。佩德里诺等待着合适的时机，随后冷静地将表哥推进压榨机，使尽全力推他，试图将他的身体塞进滚轮中。他表哥的手臂被绞到了肩膀，但身体的其他部分卡在了机器里。佩德里诺试图把表哥的头塞进滚轮，但尺寸和形状不对，导致滚轮空转却抓不住。接着，佩德里诺抓起一把修枝剪开始猛刺表哥，希望能把他切得足够碎，好把他强行塞进
through. Workers overheard the screams and raised the alarm. The boy's grandfather came to the rescue and turned the machine off. Pedrino spent several nights in jail, but as his family depended on him, they informed the police that no charges would be laid. As Pedrino was a minor, the police agreed to let him go. He was made to clean the blood and flesh off the sugarcane press as punish which took him four weeks to complete. He felt no remorse for severely wounding his cousin, instead telling the tale with amusement, saying it gave him pleasure and he had righted an injustice. A year later, Pedro Sr. was accused of stealing food and stationary from the school where he worked during his nightly patrols. He blamed the daytime guard for the crimes, but was fired with
去。工人们听到尖叫声赶来并拉响了警报。男孩的祖父赶来救援，关掉了机器。佩德里诺在监狱里度过了几个夜晚，但由于家里指望他养家糊口，他们通知警方不会对其实施起诉。由于佩德里诺是个未成年人，警方同意放了他。作为惩罚，他被迫清理甘蔗压榨机上的血迹和血肉，这花了他四个星期才完成。他对自己重伤表哥毫无悔意，反而兴致勃勃地讲述这段经历，称这给他带来了快感，并且他纠正了一次不公。一年后，老佩德罗被指控在他夜间巡逻时，从他工作的学校偷窃食物和文具。他将罪名归咎于日班保安，但最终被解雇，
no severance pay and branded a thief, making it impossible for him to get another job as a security guard. Unemployed, he was unable to provide for his family and they had to get by on the money Manuela made as a cleaner and laundress. Pedrino took to the jungle with his grandfather's rifle, hunting monkeys to sell for their pelts, which would be turned into fine leather. Things only worsened for his family and Manuela often broke down in tears. Pedrino sincerely believed the school's daytime guard was responsible for the theft and that those in a position of power refused to listen to his father's side of the story. The headmistress and the deputy mayor who had the power to hire and fire the school guards took the word of the
没有拿到遣散费，还被贴上了小偷的标签，这使得他再也无法找到保安的工作。失业在家的他无法养家糊口，全家不得不靠曼努埃拉做清洁工和洗衣妇挣来的钱度日。佩德里诺带着祖父的步枪钻进丛集，捕猎猴子并出售它们的毛皮，这些毛皮将被加工成优质皮革。家里的情况不仅没有好转，曼努埃拉还经常崩溃痛哭。佩德里诺深信学校的日班保安才是盗窃案的罪魁祸首，而那些手握权势的人却拒绝听取他父亲的辩解。有权聘用和解雇学校保安的校长和副市长，在没有分析证据的情况下，轻信了
daytime guard without analyzing the evidence. Pedrino packed his grandfather's 36 caliber rifle, ammunition, a machete and a tent into a green army backpack and went camping in the mountains for 30 days. He only hunted what was necessary to survive, cautious not to exploit the woods or mistreat the wildlife. He later explained in his autobiography Pedrino Matador, I didn't go there to live or to hide from my problems. When I got the guns, I had a plan and I already knew what I was going to do. I was going to get revenge. He returned to civilization and one night lay in wait outside the deputy mayor's house, watching as a jeep rolled up the drive. The deputy mayor emerged from the vehicle and
日班保安一面之词。佩德里诺将祖父的36口径步枪、弹药、一把大砍刀和一个帐篷装进一个绿色的军用背包里，在山里露营了30天。他只捕猎生存必需的猎物，小心翼翼地不掠夺森林或虐待野生动物。他后来在自传《杀手佩德里诺》（Pedrino Matador）中解释道：“我到那里不是为了生活，也不是为了躲避我的问题。当我拿到枪时，我有一个计划，而且我已经知道我要做什么了。我要去复仇。”他返回文明社会，一天夜里埋伏在副市长家门外，看着一辆吉普车驶入车道。副市长从车里出来，
turned in surprise at the sound of a gunshot. Pedrino fired again, killing the mayor instantly before fleeing the scene. Although the murder gave him a feeling of righteousness, he still seethed over his father's unfair treatment. A month later, Pedrino went to the school and waited in the storeroom where the daytime guard started his day. When his target arrived, Pedrino pointed the rifle at him and ordered him to sit in a chair in the middle of the room. He looked the guard in the eye and asked, did you see what you did? It destroyed my family. My brothers are starving because of you. Is it fair that you did this?
听到枪声惊讶地转身。佩德里诺再次开枪，当场打死了副市长，随后逃离现场。尽管谋杀给他带来了一种正义感，但他对父亲遭受的不公待遇依然怒火中烧。一个月后，佩德里诺来到学校，守候在日班保安开始一天工作的储藏室里。当目标出现时，佩德里诺用步枪指着他，命令他坐在房间中央的椅子上。他直视着保安的眼睛问：“你看到你做的事了吗？它毁了我的家庭。我的弟弟妹妹们因为你都在挨饿。你这么做公平吗？”
Realizing who he was, the guard began to sob, apologize, and beg for his life. Pedrino shot him twice, then covered his body with furniture and boxes. He set the pile on fire and fled. He took refuge at his godmother's house in metropolitan Sao Paulo, where he met a local woman known as Buti. The widow of a well-known drug trafficker, Buti was a gangster who used her beauty and influence to attract adolescents and children to her criminal organization. She welcomed Pedrino into her home, where she engaged him in sexual activity, despite the fact that he was only 14, and put him to work trafficking and dealing drugs. Although he had little experience,
意识到他是谁后，保安开始抽泣、道歉并乞求饶命。佩德里诺朝他开了两枪，然后用家具和箱子盖住他的尸体。他点燃了这堆东西并逃跑了。他在圣保罗大都会教母的家里避难，在那里他认识了一个当地女人，人称布蒂（Buti）。作为一个知名毒枭的遗孀，布蒂是个黑帮分子，她利用自己的美貌和影响力吸引青少年和儿童加入她的犯罪团伙。她欢迎佩德里诺来到她家，并与他发生性关系（尽管他当时只有14岁），还派他去从事毒品走私和贩卖工作。尽管他经验不多，
Pedrino's relationship with Buti enabled him to take on a higher position within the criminal hierarchy, but older and more experienced dealers were jealous and unwilling to recognize his authority. The girlfriend of one of his rivals warned him to watch his back and be prepared for an ambush when he least expected it. Shortly after, some of the other boys invited Pedrino to a local lagoon to escape the heat and smoke cannabis. As he walked down the incline toward the water, he noticed his companions were armed and acting strangely. He pulled out a gun and ordered them to drop their weapons, demanding to know why they were planning to kill him, but they turned and fled. Pedrino shot at them, killing two and severely injuring another.
但与布蒂的关系使佩德里诺在犯罪集团中占据了更高的地位，但资历更老、经验更丰富的毒贩对此感到嫉妒，不愿承认他的权威。他的一位竞争对手的女友警告他要小心背后，随时准备应对突如其来的伏击。不久之后，其他几个男孩邀请佩德里诺去当地的一个泻湖避暑并吸食大麻。当他沿着斜坡走向水边时，他注意到同伴们都带着武器，行为举止十分古怪。他拔出一枪，命令他们放下武器，质问他们为什么要密谋杀他，但他们却转身逃跑了。佩德里诺向他们开枪，当场打死两人，重伤一人。
He came to be known as Pedrino Cartuchera, or Cartridge PD, due to his weapon of choice, a two-shot, 12-gauge, sawn-off, pipe shotgun. Pedrino worked with two friends whom he trusted. The trio watched out for each other, taking it in turns to stand guard while the other two slept. Together, they carried out numerous crimes, including one in Jacareye, an industrial town located between the cities of Sao Paulo and Rio de Janeiro. They were supposed to collaborate with a drug dealer who went by the name China, but Pedrino took an immediate dislike to him, deeming him a bully and a cheat, and decided to rob him instead. The trio stole China's drugs and guns, shooting one of his men in the process
他后来被称为“佩德里诺·卡图切拉”（Pedrino Cartuchera，意为弹药匣PD），因为他惯用的武器是一把双发、12口径、锯短的管状霰弹枪。佩德里诺与两个他信任的朋友一起工作。三人互相照应，轮流放哨，另外两人则轮流睡觉。他们一起犯下了多起罪行，其中包括在雅卡雷伊（Jacareye）作案，这是一个位于圣保罗和里约热内卢两市之间的工业城镇。他们本来应该和一个化名为“中国”（China）的毒贩合作，但佩德里诺对这个人第一印象就很差，认为他是个恶霸和骗子，于是决定反过来抢劫他。三人偷走了中国的毒品和枪支，
and injuring China and his brother. Pedrino then sold the items to a dealer he respected. He soon found himself the prime target of Brazil's notorious death squads, which were vigilante groups comprised of off-duty police officers and other members of the state security forces. They roamed the streets with the aim of ridding the slums of crime, killing drug dealers, vagrants, and street children, with covert approval from the military government and invariably without consequence. In an effort to hide from both the death squads and his enemies, Pedrino became transient, sleeping in cars, cemeteries, and churches. He attended a drug transaction with his boss, Bouty, but the meeting was ambushed by police after they were tipped off by rival dealers.
在此过程中枪击了他的一个手下，并打伤了中国及其兄弟。随后，佩德里诺将这些物品卖给了一个他尊重的毒贩。不久，他发现自己成了臭名昭著的巴西行刑队的头号目标。行刑队是由下班警察和国家安全部队其他成员组成的民间自卫团伙。他们在街头游荡，旨在清除贫民窟的犯罪活动，杀死毒贩、流浪汉和街头儿童，这得到了军政府的暗中批准，且通常无需承担任何后果。为了躲避行刑队和敌人的追捕，佩德里诺开始过着居无定所的生活，睡在汽车里、墓地和教堂里。他和老板布蒂一起去参加一宗毒品交易，但由于遭到竞争对手毒贩的通风报信，会议遭到了警察的伏击。
A shootout ensued, and Bouty was killed. 16-year-old Pedrino was seriously injured, but managed to escape, taking refuge with extended family. They introduced him to Condomblema Cumba, a religion considered by some to be witchcraft or black magic. A core belief of the practice is that good and evil are irrelevant. Worshippers are taught to fully embrace and accomplish their life purpose, but are reminded that any harm inflicted on another person will come back to the person who caused the injury. Rituals included offerings, ceremonial dancing, and animal sacrifices. Blood is used in many of the rituals, as it is believed to represent life's pure essence and is considered the most sacred and symbolic substance.
枪战随之爆发，布蒂被杀。16岁的佩德里诺身受重伤，但设法逃脱，并投奔了远亲。他们将他引荐给孔东布莱马孔巴（Condomblema Cumba），这是一种被一些人视为巫术或黑魔法的宗教。这种信仰的核心信念是善恶无关紧要。信徒被教导要完全拥抱并实现他们的生命目的，但同时也被提醒，对他人造成的任何伤害最终都会报应在施害者身上。仪式包括祭品、仪式舞蹈和动物献祭。血液被用在许多仪式中，因为人们相信它代表了生命的纯粹本质，被认为是最神圣和象征性的物质。
Pedrino willingly joined the religion, and his hair and eyebrows were shaved as part of his indoctrination. His initiation ceremony took place in a deserted quarry at midnight, overseen by a dozen believers who danced to drum beats. He was required to kill a cat and drink its blood before placing its entrails all over his body. The carcass was then filled with seeds and buried. Pedrino believed the ritual had possessed him with powers of invincibility. He returned to the site a week later to dig up the cat's body and remove the seeds within, which had since hardened into beads. His uncle threaded them into a necklace and placed it around Pedrino's neck, warning him to never take it off. In his autobiography, Pedrino wrote,
佩德里诺自愿加入了这个宗教，作为入教仪式的一部分，他的头发和眉毛被剃光了。他的入教仪式于午夜在一个荒废的采石场举行，由十几位随着鼓点起舞的信徒监督。他被要求杀死一只猫并喝下它的血，然后把猫的内脏涂满全身。接着，尸体被填满种子并掩埋。佩德里诺相信这个仪式赋予了他刀枪不入的力量。一周后，他回到现场挖出猫的尸体，取出里面已经变硬成珠子的种子。他的叔叔把它们穿成一条项链挂在佩德里诺的脖子上，并警告他永远不要取下来。佩德里诺在自传中写道：
From then on, the cops opened fire, but the bullets didn't hit me. The enemies attacked, and I defended myself with ease. Nothing would stop me. Before, I was afraid, but after the ceremony, it was as if nothing could affect me. From that moment on, Pedrino saw himself as a defender of the weak and vulnerable. He hijacked food trucks to feed residents of slums, burned shops if he believed the owners had cheated customers, and killed men who harmed women. His penalty for cruelty to animals was to inflict the same acts on the perpetrator. He stole from drug dealers he deemed bad, and sold their product to others he considered righteous.
从那时起，警察开枪射击，但子弹没有击中我。敌人发动攻击，我轻而易举地进行了自卫。没有什么能阻止我。以前我很害怕，但在仪式之后，似乎没有什么能影响我了。从那一刻起，佩德里诺把自己视为弱者和弱势群体的守护者。他劫持运送食物的卡车来喂养贫民窟的居民，如果认为店主欺骗了顾客，他就会烧毁店铺，并杀死伤害妇女的男子。他对虐待动物的惩罚是以其人之道还治其人之身。他从他认为不好的毒贩那里偷窃，并将他们的毒品卖给那些他认为是正直的人。
He moved to Campo Grandi, a neighborhood in the west of Rio de Janeiro, where he fell in love with a girl named Maria her parasita Olympia. Maria soon became pregnant, and the young couple moved into a modest shack. Pedrino continued his vigilantism, regarding it as legally wrong, but morally just. When Maria was seven months pregnant, Pedrino arrived home to find that she had been murdered, along with their unborn child, and the man appointed to protect them. The killers had used Maria's blood to scroll the words we will get you on the wall. By this point, Pedrino had so many enemies that he couldn't immediately conclude who was responsible, and spent more than a year trying to find out, sometimes torturing informants for information.
他搬到了里约热内卢西部的一个社区格兰德营（Campo Grandi），在那里他爱上了一个名叫玛丽亚·帕拉西塔·奥林匹亚（Maria parasita Olympia）的女孩。玛丽亚很快怀孕了，这对年轻夫妇搬进了一间简陋的小屋。佩德里诺继续他的私刑正义，他认为这在法律上是错的，但在道德上是正义的。当玛丽亚怀孕七个月时，佩德里诺回到家，发现她和他们未出生的孩子以及被派去保护他们的人都被谋杀了。凶手用玛丽亚的血在墙上潦草地写下了“我们要抓到你”这几个字。此时此刻，佩德里诺的敌人实在太多，以至于他无法立刻断定是谁干的，并花了一年多的时间去调查，有时甚至通过折磨线人来获取信息。
His inquiries went nowhere, until he stopped at a bar one day and was told a young woman from the Parayiba Valley who drove a jeep was looking for him. Pedrino discovered she was the ex-wife of China, the drug dealer he had encountered and confronted two years prior. She showed the scars, bruises and burn marks China had inflicted across her body, and revealed that it was him who warded Maria's murder. Pedrino was frustrated that he hadn't suspected China sooner, given their hostile history. He found out that China's brother was getting married the following Saturday, and recruited two friends to go with him, ordering that every man in attendance be shot. He warned that no women or children were to be harmed, stating,
他的调查陷入了死胡同，直到有一天他在一家酒吧停下，得知帕拉伊巴山谷（Parayiba Valley）有一个开吉普车的年轻女人在找他。佩德里诺发现她是“中国”的前妻，也就是他两年前遇到并与之对抗的那个毒贩。她展示了中国在她身上留下的伤疤、瘀青和烧伤痕迹，并透露正是中国策划了对玛丽亚的谋杀。考虑到他们之间敌对的历史，佩德里诺感到很懊恼，自己竟然没有早点怀疑中国。他发现中国的哥哥将在接下来星期六结婚，于是招募了两个朋友和他一起去，并下令将出席婚礼的每个男人都枪决。他警告说，绝不能伤害妇女或儿童，并声称：
if you shoot them, you are going to have to deal with me. The wedding celebrations were in full swing when Pedrino and his friends snuck in pretending to be invited guests and knocked on the door to the reception hall. An older man answered, and Pedrino told him, I am an honored guest of China. I believe the most awaited guest of the night. Pedrino and his cohorts burst into the venue, ordering all women and children upstairs. China came at Pedrino with a revolver, but Pedrino shot him in the chest with his trademark 12 gauge shotgun, killing him instantly. They continued shooting indiscriminately, stopping when their ammunition ran low, and then calmly walked through the carnage and to the bar
如果你向他们开枪，你就得跟我过不去。婚礼庆典正如火如荼地进行着，佩德里诺和他的朋友们假装成受邀宾客溜了进去，并敲响了接待大厅的门。一个老年人开了门，佩德里诺告诉他：“我是中国的尊贵客人。我想我是今晚最受期待的客人。”佩德里诺和他的同伙冲进会场，命令所有妇女和儿童上楼。中国拿着左轮手枪冲向佩德里诺，但佩德里诺用他标志性的12口径霰弹枪击中了中国的胸膛，当场将其击毙。他们继续无差别地开枪，直到弹药耗尽才停下来，然后平静地穿过血腥的屠杀现场来到酒吧
for a drink. In total, seven men had been killed, and 16 others were injured. The only woman hurt was China's mother, whose arm had been wounded in an attempt to protect her son. Pedrino would later claim that the injury was her own fault. News of the wedding massacre spread, earning 18-year-old Pedrino the nickname Pedrino Matador, which translated to Little Pete the Killer or Killer P.D. His unbridled and merciless obsession with retribution made him a fearful figure, but some commended him for his reputation as a protector of women and children. Pedrino adopted the lifestyle of a cashed-up gangster and initiated a polyamorous relationship
喝一杯。总共有七名男子被杀，另有16人受伤。唯一受伤的女性是中国的母亲，她在试图保护儿子时手臂受伤。佩德里诺后来声称，这次受伤是她自己的错。婚礼大屠杀的消息传开后，18岁的佩德里诺赢得了“佩德里诺·马塔多尔”（Pedrino Matador）的绰号，翻译过来就是“小皮特杀手”或“杀手PD”。他对复仇的肆无忌惮和冷酷无情的执念使他成为了一个令人闻风丧胆的人物，但有些人因为他作为妇女和儿童保护者的名声而赞扬他。佩德里诺过上了腰缠万贯的黑帮生活，并与一对双胞胎姐妹开始了多边恋关系。
with twin sisters. He reveled in his notoriety and the fear his presence had among those he considered scum, saying, I had money, morals, respect, and power. He worked to make sure criminals were more afraid of him than they were of the death squads. Adding to the plethora of body art he'd already accumulated, he tattooed the words I kill for pleasure on the inside of his right forearm. On his left arm, he tattooed Maria's name and the inscription I can kill for love. He would later tell journalist Herberto Cabrini on television news program connects our reporter that he killed every day during this period. If a day went by without killing someone, he became agitated. He told the reporter,
他陶醉于自己的声名狼藉以及他在那些他认为是败类的人中间所引起的恐惧，说道：“我有钱、有道德、有尊严、有权力。”他努力确保罪犯对他的恐惧超过对行刑队的恐惧。为了给他已经积累的丰富纹身再添一笔，他在右前臂内侧纹上了“我为快乐而杀人”这几个字。在他的左臂上，他纹上了玛丽亚的名字和“我能为爱而杀人”的铭文。他后来在电视新闻节目《联系我们的记者》（Connects Our Reporter）上告诉记者赫伯托·卡布里尼（Herberto Cabrini），他在这一时期每天都在杀人。如果有一天没有杀人，他就会变得烦躁不安。他告诉记者：
I would summon the devil. It was a ritual. It was like, it's yours. This body is yours. This blood is yours. He drank the blood of his victims, believing it made him stronger. Brazilian law enforcement embarked on a manhunt to track Pedrino down. As a result, several of his trusted associates and friends were killed, causing his paranoia to grow. He trusted no one and constantly felled as though police were closing in on him. On May 24, 1973, Pedrino was having a drink at a bar where the father of his twin girlfriend's worked. Unbeknownst to him, the twin's father had alerted police of his presence and they soon stormed the building. Pedrino was wounded in the subsequent gunfight. Before he lost consciousness,
我会召唤魔鬼。这是一个仪式。就像是，它是你的。这具身体是你的。这些鲜血是你的。他喝下受害者的血，相信这能使他变得更强大。巴西执法部门展开了追捕佩德里诺的行动。结果，他的一些信任的同伙和朋友被杀，导致他的多疑日益加重。他不信任任何人，时刻觉得警察正在逼近他。1973年5月24日，佩德里诺正在一家酒吧喝酒，这家酒吧的老板是他的双胞胎女友的父亲。在他不知情的情况下，双胞胎的父亲向警方通报了他的行踪，警察随即突袭了这栋建筑。佩德里诺在随后的枪战中受伤。在他失去知觉之前，
he heard the officers screaming for his death. He awoke chained to a hospital bed surrounded by nurses, police and reporters to witness the moment killer Pedi was formally charged with murder. He spent 25 days recovering in the hospital, completely restrained and under 24 hour guard. When he was well enough to be transferred to prison, he was provided with the option of going into protective custody or general population, where the friends, brothers and sons of many of his victims were serving sentences. Pedrino chose to go into the general population. He basked in his newfound celebrity, but was disappointed upon learning he would only be charged with 18 homicides, telling the court,
他听到警官们疯狂地喊叫着要他死。他醒来时被铁链锁在医院的病床上，周围环绕着护士、警察和记者，他们共同见证了杀手佩迪被正式指控谋杀的那一刻。他在医院里度过了25天的康复期，全身被束缚，并受到24小时的监护。当他身体恢复到可以转移到监狱时，他被提供了两个选项：进入保护性拘留所，或是进入普通牢房，那里关押着他的许多受害者的朋友、兄弟和儿子。佩德里诺选择了进入普通牢房。他沉浸在自己新获得的“名气”中，但当得知自己只被指控犯有18起谋杀案时，他感到很失望，并对法庭说：
only that it cannot be that little. Pedrino insisted he had killed more than 100 men, but was convicted of only 14 murders and given a sentence of 126 years in prison. When transferring Pedrino to the jailhouse, officers put him in the back of the police wagon with a serial rapist. By the time they reached their destination, Killer Pedi had claimed another life. Brazilian prisons are notorious for being some of the toughest and most violent in the world. In the early 1970s, conditions were particularly overcrowded, unsanitary, unsafe and inhumane, with infectious diseases such as tuberculosis and dengue fever spreading easily. The average life expectancy for a prisoner was low, and it was almost unheard of for an
怎么会这么少。佩德里诺坚称自己杀了一百多人，但最终仅被判14起谋杀罪成立，获刑126年监禁。在将佩德里诺转移到监狱时，警官把他和一个连环强奸犯关在警车后面。等他们到达目的地时，杀手佩迪已经夺走了另一条生命。巴西的监狱以世界上最艰难、最暴力而闻名。20世纪70年代初，监狱环境异常拥挤、不卫生、不安全且极其不人道，结核病和登革热等传染病肆意传播。囚犯的平均寿命很短，几乎没有哪个囚犯能在监狱里存活15年而没有死于疾病或仇人之手。位于圣保罗的阿拉夸拉（Araraquara）监狱是佩德里诺将要服刑的地方，也是最残酷的监狱之一，残忍的殴打每天都在发生，死亡事件几乎同样频繁。
inmate to survive in jail for 15 years without dying of disease or at the hands of an enemy. A raraquara prison in Sao Paulo, where Pedrino would be serving his time, was one of the roughest, with brutal bashings occurring daily and deaths almost as frequent. Dozens of prisoners were sometimes held in a single small cell where there was not even enough room to lie down. Prison guards were considered insensitive, crude and indifferent. The worst of them were sadistic or corrupt and willing to accept a bribe to break rules. The underpaid and outnumbered staff largely left prisoners to their own devices. Guards would hand over the keys to internal locks to whichever inmates were running the show, with their own job
有时数十名囚犯被关押在一个狭小的牢房里，里面甚至没有足够的空间躺下。狱警们被认为麻木不仁、粗俗冷漠。其中最糟糕的更是虐待狂或腐败分子，为了打破规矩甘愿接受贿赂。薪水过低且人数处于劣势的工作人员基本对囚犯采取放任自流的态度。狱警会将内部锁的钥匙交给出头管事的犯人们，而他们自己的工作仅限于
confined to securing the outside of the prison. Weapons, drugs and even women were smuggled in on occasion. For most inmates, the only way to stay safe was to join a gang that provided protection. Gang warfare pitted criminals from different cities against each other and the resulting battles would often end in prisoners being decapitated or disemboweled in displays of power. Pedrino entered prison young even by Brazilian standards, where half of all male prisoners were aged between 20 and 29. Even though the grim reputation of regional prisons was well known, he was completely unprepared for what awaited him. In his autobiography, he wrote, By the time I went through processing, I began to understand what I would go through.
保卫监狱外围。武器、毒品甚至女人有时也会被偷运进来。对大多数囚犯来说，保持安全的唯一方法就是加入一个能提供保护的帮派。帮派战争让来自不同城市的罪犯互相厮杀，由此引发的战斗往往以囚犯被斩首或剖腹来展示力量而告终。佩德里诺进入监狱时还很年轻，即使按巴西的标准来看也是如此——在巴西，一半的男囚犯年龄在20岁到29岁之间。尽管地方监狱的残酷声誉广为人知，但他对等待着他的这一切完全没有准备。他在自传中写道：“当我完成入狱手续时，我开始明白我将经历什么。
The cell was small. There was no mattress. There was nothing. Just the frozen concrete floor. There was no shower. It was just a water nozzle. There was no toilet. There was only a hole in the floor. As the newest arrival, Pedrino's sleeping area was closest to the toilet hole. From the moment he arrived, his crimes, reputation and to no deriety made him the target of other prisoners. With the help of a cellmate, Pedrino fashioned a knife by sharpening a spoon into a coin that he carried with him at all times. When he first entered the prison yard, five men surrounded him while other inmates silently watched on. Reports differ over what happened next, but three of the men who ambushed Pedrino were killed
牢房很小。没有床垫。什么都没有。只有冰冷的混凝土地面。没有淋浴。只有一个水龙头。没有厕所。地上只有一个洞。”作为新来的人，佩德里诺的睡觉地方离马桶洞最近。从他到达的那一刻起，他的罪行、声誉和臭名昭著就让他成为了其他囚犯的目标。在同牢犯人的帮助下，佩德里诺把一把勺子磨成硬币大小的刀，制作了一把刀，他随身携带。当他第一次进入监狱操场时，五名男子包围了他，而其他囚犯则在一旁静静地看着。关于接下来发生的事情，报道各有不同，但伏击佩德里诺的三人被杀，
and the remaining two were badly wounded. It quickly became known that Pedrino would kill without hesitation. When he wasn't using makeshift shives or illegally obtained weapons, he relied on his bare hands to break fellow prisoners' necks. He taught himself martial arts and trained himself to withstand pain, punching the walls of his cell until they were covered in blood. He plotted his murders methodically, often befriending his target over weeks or months by sharing food or belongings with them and even lowering dead offenses by hugging them, before striking when they least suspected. Pedrino's mother and grandmother came to visit every week. One night after a visit from his mother, he went to sleep early while his cellmate stayed
其余两人身受重伤。人们很快就知道佩德里诺杀人毫不犹豫。当他没有使用自制的削尖利器或非法获得的武器时，他依靠双手扭断狱友的颈骨。他自学武术，并训练自己忍受痛苦，用拳头击打牢房的墙壁，直到墙上布满鲜血。他有条不紊地策划谋杀，常常通过与目标分享食物或物品甚至拥抱他们来降低他们的戒心，从而在他们最不防备的时候发起袭击，通过几周或几个月的时间与目标建立友谊。佩德里诺的母亲和祖母每周都来探视。在母亲来访后的一个夜晚，他早早地去睡觉了，而他的同牢犯人则熬夜喝酒、吸食可卡因和赌博。
up drinking, snorting cocaine and gambling. Pedrino woke up to use the toilet and noticed some of his cellmates were acting strangely, turning down the radio as he passed. The next day, he caught prisoners sneaking glances at him in the yard and noticed they abruptly changed their topics of conversation when he approached. He headed to the gym area to begin his two-hour workout, which involved lifting makeshift weights fashioned from plastic bottles filled with water tied to either end of a broomstick. During his workout, a guard approached and summoned Pedrino to the prison director's office. The director informed him that his mother, Manuela Rodriguez, had been hacked to death by a machete while she slept.
佩德里诺醒来去上厕所，注意到他的一些同牢犯人举止异常，当他路过时把收音机音量调低了。第二天，他在操场上发现囚犯们偷偷瞥向他，并注意到当他走近时，他们突然改变了谈话主题。他前往健身区开始他为期两小时的锻炼，其中包括举起用系在扫帚杆两端的装满水的塑料瓶制成的简易哑铃。在他锻炼时，一名狱警走近并把佩德里诺叫到了监狱长办公室。监狱长通知他，他的母亲曼努埃拉·罗德里格斯在睡梦中被砍刀残忍杀害。
Reports of the murder had been broadcast on local radio, which the inmates had heard, but no one wanted to be the one to tell him. Pedrino's father, Pedro Rodriguez Sr., had been charged with the murder and taken into custody. Pedrino accepted the offer to see his mother in the morgue before her burial. As he stood over her coffin, he vowed to avenge her death. A week later, he was told his paternal aunt had visited the prison and left a cake for him as a peace offering. Pedrino divided the dessert among his soulmates and the stray dogs that some of the prisoners kept as pets. Soon after, one puppy started vomiting and another collapsed. One of his soulmates also began vomiting. The cake was tested, revealing it had been laced with poison.
谋杀的消息已经在当地广播中播出，囚犯们都听到了，但没有人愿意做那个把消息告诉他的人。佩德里诺的父亲老佩德罗·罗德里格斯已被指控谋杀并被拘留。佩德里诺接受了在母亲下葬前去太平间看她一眼的提议。当他站在她的棺材上方时，他发誓要为她报仇。一周后，有人告诉他，他父亲的妹妹曾来监狱探视，并给他留下了一个蛋糕作为求和礼物。佩德里诺把甜点分给了他的狱友和一些囚犯当宠物养的流浪狗。不久之后，一只小狗开始呕吐，另一只则瘫倒在地。他的一名狱友也开始呕吐。经过检测，蛋糕被发现掺有毒药。
Pedrino was interrogated and transferred to another penitentiary, the same one where his father was being held. Although, Pedro Rodriguez Sr. was locked away in a different section of the prison for his own safety. One day, Pedrino called a guard to his cell under the guise of being ill. Using a knife he had managed to acquire, he threatened the guard and took away his gun and keys. He used the gun to shepherd other guards into a cell, locking them in before making his way to the block where his father was being held. The other inmates promptly scattered. Pedro Sr. did not attempt to run, but instead stood in the corner near a wall. As Pedrino approached, his father said,
佩德里诺接受了审讯，并被转移到另一所监狱——关押他父亲的同一所监狱。不过，老佩德罗为了自身安全，被关在监狱的不同区域。一天，佩德里诺以生病为由把一名狱警叫到他的牢房。他利用设法弄到的一把刀威胁狱警，并夺走了他的枪和钥匙。他用枪把其他狱警赶进一个牢房，将他们锁在里面，然后前往关押他父亲的牢区。其他囚犯立刻四散逃窜。老佩德罗没有试图逃跑，而是站在靠近墙壁的角落里。当佩德里诺走近时，他的父亲说：
You are right, my son. The pair grappled and fell to the ground. Pedrino climbed on top of his father and stabbed him 22 times. One blow more than Pedro Sr. had administered to his wife. Pedrino had promised his deceased mother one final act of vengeance. He removed his father's heart, placed it on the ground, sliced off a piece, and put it in his mouth. It was tough and chewy, and Pedrino couldn't bring himself to swallow it, so he spat it out onto his father's body. A few seconds later, Pedrino made his way back to his cell and released the guards he had locked away. He handed them the knife and gun and allowed himself to be handcuffed and taken away. Although Pedrino knew he would likely remain in prison for the rest of his life, he felt he
你说得对，我的儿子。两人扭打在一起，双双倒地。佩德里诺爬到父亲身上，连捅了22刀。比老佩德罗对他妻子下手的次数多了一刀。佩德里诺曾向死去的母亲承诺最后一次复仇。他掏出父亲的心脏，把它放在地上，切下一小块放进嘴里。它又老又韧，佩德里诺怎么也咽不下去，于是把它吐在了父亲的尸体上。几秒钟后，佩德里诺回到自己的牢房，释放了被他锁起来的狱警。他把刀和枪交还给他们，任由自己被戴上手铐带走。尽管佩德里诺知道他很可能会在监狱里度过余生，但他觉得
shouldn't have to exist alongside criminals he deemed unworthy of living. Following his self-imposed moral code, he continued to target rapists, pedophiles, and men who murdered women or children. He was given the nickname the Punisher after the Marvel Comics vigilante character who employed lethal methods in his campaign against crime. Pedrino mostly kept to himself, but occasionally befriended and protected other inmates, such as a prisoner named Cloudu. When Cloudu was due to be released, he promised he would help his protector escape. Pedrino gave Cloudu the address to his grandmother's house, where he would be welcomed and provided with assistance. There, Cloudu became romantically involved with Pedrino's sister, Silvana.
自己不应该与那些他认为不配活着的罪犯共存。遵循他自己奉行的道德准则，他继续将强奸犯、恋童癖以及谋杀妇女或儿童的男子作为目标。他得到了“惩罚者”（the Punisher）的绰号，这个名字取自漫威漫画中的反英雄角色，该角色在打击犯罪的行动中采取致命手段。佩德里诺大多独来独往，但偶尔也会与一些狱友交朋友并保护他们，比如一个名叫克劳杜（Cloudu）的囚犯。当克劳杜刑满释放时，他承诺会帮助他的保护人越狱。佩德里诺给了克劳杜他祖母家的地址，他在那里将受到欢迎并获得帮助。在那里，克劳杜与佩德里诺的妹妹西尔瓦娜（Silvana）陷入了爱河。
However, one night, Pedrino's brother disrespected Cloudu, hitting him and accusing him of having a sexual relationship with Pedrino in prison. Consumed with rage, Cloudu fired his gun indiscriminately, accidentally killing Silvana and wounding her friend. Cloudu was sent back to prison, where Pedrino reassured him that he bore no grudge for his sister's death and resumed his role as Cloudu's protector. One day, Cloudu was studying in his cell when Pedrino approached. Without saying a word, he pulled Cloudu's head back by the hair and used a knife to violently decapitate him. Pedrino later stated he was satisfied his sister had been avenged. Quote, he was my friend, but I just had to kill him. I'm justified.
然而，一天晚上，佩德里诺的弟弟对克劳杜很不尊重，殴打了他，并指责他在监狱里与佩德里诺有性关系。克劳杜怒火中烧，盲目地开枪，不小心杀死了西尔瓦娜并打伤了她的朋友。克劳杜被送回监狱，佩德里诺向他保证，他对妹妹的死没有任何怨恨，并恢复了他作为克劳杜保护者的角色。一天，克劳杜正在牢房里学习，佩德里诺走了过来。他一言不发地抓住克劳杜的头发把他的头往后拉，然后用刀残忍地将他斩首。佩德里诺后来表示，他为妹妹报了仇感到很满意。“引述：他是我的朋友，但我不得不杀了他。我是正义的。”
When he wasn't lifting weights, practicing martial arts, or killing his fellow inmates, Pedrino learned to read and write. He started receiving fan mail and love letters from the public, along with letters asking him to write the wrongs his fellow inmates had committed on the outside. If the writer seemed genuine, Pedrino would oblige the request, refusing to accept any money. He claimed to receive up to 50 letters per week, including several marriage proposals. He ignored most of the romantic requests, but started corresponding with a female prisoner, and the two developed a relationship. They wrote to each other regularly for years, and finally met in person when the woman was released.
除了举重、练习武术或杀死狱友之外，佩德里诺还学会了读书写字。他开始收到公众的粉丝信和情书，以及要求他纠正狱友在外面犯下的错误的信件。如果寄信人看起来很真诚，佩德里诺会满足这个请求，拒绝接受任何金钱。他声称每周最多能收到50封信，其中包括几份求婚信。他对大多数浪漫的请求置之不理，但开始与一名女囚通信，两人发展出了一段恋情。他们多年来定期通信，最后在那个女人出狱后亲自见面了。
Prison psychiatrists diagnosed Pedrino as a psychopath incapable of feeling remorse or sympathy, in addition to suffering from paranoia and antisocial personality disorder. During a psychological evaluation in 1982, Pedrino's greatest motivation in life was detailed as a violent affirmation of self. Although, psychologists believed his rage was targeted solely on those who committed wrongdoings, and he was otherwise harmless to law-abiding society. Like many serial killers, Pedrino collected newspaper clippings about his life and crimes. During his prison term, he faced trial for several murders. He described his motivation for one as, quote,
监狱精神科医生诊断佩德里诺为患有偏执狂和反社会人格障碍的心理 psychopath，无法感到后悔或同情。在1982年的一次心理评估中，佩德里诺生活中的最大动力被详细描述为对自我的暴力肯定。不过，心理学家认为，他的怒火纯粹针对那些作恶的人，对遵纪守法的社会而言，他并没有其他危害。和许多连环杀手一样，佩德里诺收集了关于他的生活和罪行的剪报。在服刑期间，他因多起谋杀案受审。他将其中一起案件的动机描述为：
I did not like his face, and said that another of his victims snored too much. Pedrino later told reporter Humberto Cabrini that he was just being flippant with the court, and his motivations were much more complicated. He explained one murder occurred when he and another inmate were housed in a private hospice room after a prison riot. There, Pedrino received a visit from his girlfriend, and as the couple became intimate, Pedrino noticed his roommate was staring. He ended up killing him for his disrespect and rudeness. The squalor, boredom, and idleness of Brazil's prison system exacerbated Pedrino's
我不喜欢他的脸，并说他的另一名受害者鼾声太大。佩德里诺后来告诉记者翁贝托·卡布里尼（Humberto Cabrini），他当时只是在法庭上显得轻率，他的动机要复杂得多。他解释说，其中一起谋杀发生在一场监狱骚乱后，他和另一名狱友被安置在一个私人临终关怀病房里。在那里，佩德里诺收到了女友的探视，正当两人亲热时，佩德里诺注意到他的室友正盯着看。他最终因室友的不尊重和粗鲁而杀了他。巴西监狱系统的肮脏、无聊和闲散加剧了佩德里诺的
psychiatric problems and paranoia, prompting him to kill for increasingly pointless reasons. He served his time in nine different institutions, continuing his killing spree in H1. The details of his most horrific attack are questionable, as the only public record appears to be Pedrino's account of the event years later, during an interview with the journalist Humberto Cabrini. After one of his friends was killed as a result of what Pedrino believed to be lies spread by a transgender inmate, he claimed to have rampaged through a section of a prison where transgender inmates were held, taking 16 lives in retribution.
精神问题和多疑症，促使他以越来越荒谬的理由杀人。他在九个不同的机构服刑，并在H1继续他的杀戮狂潮。他最恐怖袭击的细节令人怀疑，因为唯一的公开记录似乎是佩德里诺多年后在接受记者翁贝托·卡布里尼采访时对事件的叙述。在其中的一个朋友因佩德里诺认为是由一名跨性别囚犯散布的谎言而被杀后，他声称自己在一处关押跨性别囚犯的监狱区域大开杀戒，夺走了16条生命作为报复。
Pedrino claimed the blood-curdling screams of his victims was so intense that he lost his hearing for three days. By this point in time, 71 murders had been definitively attributed to Pedrino and his cumulative sentence totaled 400 years. In 1985, authorities decided to transfer him to a psychiatric ward, ordering he was to have no contact with other patients. Pedrino was transferred to Talbate Maximum Security Prison and Psychiatric Treatment Center, approximately 80 miles outside Sao Paulo. The center had a custom-built annex designed to house inmates considered too dangerous to be kept in the general prison system. Prisoners spent most of their day in tiny individual cells and were only allowed out
佩德里诺声称，受害者撕心裂肺的尖叫声如此强烈，以至于他失聪了三天。此时此刻，71起谋杀案已被明确归咎于佩德里诺，他的累计刑期达到了400年。1985年，当局决定将他转移到精神病房，并下令他不得与任何其他病人接触。佩德里诺被转移到位于圣保罗郊外约80英里的陶巴特最高安全监狱和精神治疗中心（Talbate Maximum Security Prison and Psychiatric Treatment Center）。该中心有一个专门建造的附属建筑，旨在收容被认为过于危险而无法关押在普通监狱系统中的囚犯。囚犯们一整天大部分时间都在狭小的单人牢房里度过，只有在严格监督下才被允许出来
to eat and exercise under strict supervision. These methods were so effective that Pedrino stopped killing. Instead, he distracted himself by reading, writing letters, playing solitaire, and repeatedly punching the wall of his cell until he was given a bag of sand as an alternative. In Pedrino's dreams, his victims sometimes visited him in the form of animals such as snakes, panthers, tigers, rats, and monkeys. He always knew exactly which creature represented which victim, and in his dreams, he would kill them again. His father appeared the most. Pedrino later told journalist Roberto Cabrini, he would appear to be a snake and, in my dream, he attacked me, biting me, and I would hold him
吃饭和锻炼。这些方法非常奏效，以至于佩德里诺停止了杀戮。相反，他通过阅读、写信、玩纸牌游戏以及反复击打牢房墙壁来转移注意力，直到他得到一袋沙子作为替代品。在佩德里诺的梦中，他的受害者有时会以蛇、美洲豹、老虎、老鼠和猴子等动物的形态来看望他。他总是确切地知道哪只生物代表哪个受害者，并且在梦中，他会再次杀死他们。他的父亲出现得最多。佩德里诺后来告诉记者罗伯托·卡布里尼（Roberto Cabrini），他会变成一条蛇出现，并且在我的梦中，他袭击了我，咬了我，而我会抓住他
and tell him, I killed you, that's right, and I will kill you again, and I would crush the snake that was speaking. It was a snake, but it was my father speaking. In the early 1990s, a former plastic surgeon named Hosmen Ye Hamos was transferred to Taupate. Hamos had been sentenced to 53 years for airplane theft, car smuggling, and murdering his personal pilot and flight attendant. According to Pedrino, Hamos snitched to the wardens about a younger prisoner's plans to escape, and when Pedrino approached him in the lunchroom to discuss the matter, Hamos hit him in the mouth. Pedrino launched an attack, knocking Hamos to the ground and holding his foot on his neck, but guards quickly intervened. From then on, Pedrino was restricted
并且告诉他，我杀了你，没错，而且我还会再杀了你，我会捏碎那条正在说话的蛇。那是一条蛇，但说话的是我的父亲。20世纪90年代初，一名前整形外科医生霍斯门·叶·哈莫斯被转押至陶巴特。哈莫斯因盗窃飞机、走货车以及谋杀他的私人飞行员和空乘人员而被判处53年监禁。据佩德里诺称，哈莫斯向看守告密，称一名年轻囚犯有越狱计划，当佩德里诺在餐厅找他理论时，哈莫斯打了他的嘴。佩德里诺随即发动袭击，将哈莫斯打倒在地，并用脚踩住他的脖子，但警卫很快介入。从那时起，佩德里诺被限制
to weeding alone in his cell and the feud between the two prisoners escalated. Pedrino claimed a fellow prisoner once handed him a piece of cake through the bars of his cell, and when he bit into it, his mouth started to bleed. Realising the cake had been poisoned, he quickly swallowed a whole can of powdered milk to detoxify. He was certain Hamos sent the cake, but never had the chance to confront him. Hamos was eventually released and resumed practicing plastic surgery. From 1992 to 2002, Pedrino was kept in complete isolation and only had contact with the guards, whom he was always polite and respectful to. He was only permitted to be in the exercise yard alone, under supervision by two guards who were prepared to shoot him if
在单人牢房里独自拔草，两名囚犯之间的宿怨也随之升级。佩德里诺声称，曾有同监犯人透过牢房的铁栏杆递给他一块蛋糕，当他咬下去时，嘴里开始流血。意识到蛋糕有毒后，他赶紧吞下一整罐奶粉来解毒。他确信蛋糕是哈莫斯送的，但一直没机会跟他对质。哈莫斯最终获释并恢复了整形医生的工作。从1992年到2002年，佩德里诺被关在完全隔离的环境中，只能与看守接触，他对看守总是既礼貌又尊敬。他只被允许在两名全副武装、随时准备开枪的警卫监督下，独自在放风场活动。
he stepped out of line. Public interest in killer Pedi was still strong, and daring journalists continued to visit him on occasion. To one, he remarked that the prison staff had no reason to fear him because he only killed scoundrels. In August 1996, during a televised interview from inside the prison, reporter Eduardo Fostini asked Pedrino if he would kill again should he ever be released. He responded calmly, yes, I would have to. To put it simply, I'm a murderer. I always have been. In 1998, another notorious inmate arrived at the prison. Motoboy Francisco de Cisperera was a serial killer better known as the Park Maniac. Posing as a talent scout for a modeling
公众对杀手佩蒂的兴趣依然浓厚，大胆的记者们也偶尔继续前去探视他。他对其中一人说，监狱工作人员没有理由害怕他，因为他只杀恶人。1996年8月，在监狱内的一次电视采访中，记者爱德华多·福斯蒂尼问佩德里诺，如果有一天他获释，是否还会杀人。他平静地回答，是的，我不得不这么做。简而言之，我是一个杀人犯。我一直都是。1998年，另一名声名狼藉的犯人来到了这座监狱。摩托车手弗朗西斯科·德·西斯佩雷拉是一名连环杀手，更为人熟知的名字是“公园魔头”。他伪装成模特经纪公司的星探，
agency, he had lured female victims to São Paulo's State Park where he proceeded to rape and torture them. He also strangled 11 of his victims to death and was sentenced to 268 years for 20 attacks. A visiting journalist asked Pedrino what he thought about the new inmate, to which he responded. Today, my biggest dream is to be alone with him. My dream is to break that neck. What he did should not be done. He killed a lot of helpless girls. I hate rapist murderers. Pedrino's declaration to kill the Park Maniac made national headlines. In response, the prison director released a statement assuring the public there was no way he would make good on his threat, telling the press. Even if Pedrino can get out of the cell,
将女性受害者引诱到圣保罗州立公园，然后对她们进行强奸和折磨。他还勒死了11名受害者，因20起袭击事件被判处268年监禁。一名来访的记者问佩德里诺对这个新来的犯人有什么看法，他回答说，今天，我最大的梦想就是能单独和他待在一起。我的梦想就是扭断那家伙的脖子。他做的事情是不应该发生的。他杀了很多无助的女孩。我痛恨强奸犯和杀人犯。佩德里诺要杀死“公园魔头”的宣言登上了全国各大报纸的头条。作为回应，监狱长发表了一份声明，向公众保证他绝不可能兑现威胁，他告诉媒体，就算佩德里诺能离开牢房，
he will not know where to find Francisco. In addition, the two were always accompanied by prison guards. During visiting hours on December 17, 2000, a Tao Batae inmate managed to smuggle a gun in and opened fire on prisoners from a rival gang. Amid the ensuing chaos, inmates assumed control of the facility and took 23 hostages, including four children. Over the course of the standoff, prisoners negotiated the transfer of 10 inmates to another facility, releasing hostages in small groups in return. News filtered through that prison gangs were taking advantage of the situation to exact revenge on their rivals, with several murders taking place. The Park Maniac was amongst those reportedly killed as he was missing from his cell,
他也找不到弗朗西斯科在哪里。此外，这两人身边总是由狱警陪同。2000年12月17日探视期间，陶巴特的一名囚犯设法走私了一把枪，并向敌对帮派的囚犯开枪。在随后的混战中，囚犯们控制了监狱，劫持了23名人质，其中包括4名儿童。在对峙过程中，囚犯们谈判将10名囚犯转移到另一所监狱，作为交换，他们分小批释放了人质。有消息传出，监狱帮派正利用这一局势向死敌复仇，发生了多起谋杀案。“公园魔头”据信也在遇害者之列，因为他的牢房里不见了他的踪影，
leading to speculation that killer Petey had gone through with his threat. All of the hostages were at least unharmed one day later, reporting that their captors had treated them well throughout the ordeal, and that Pedrino had brought them food and kept them comfortable. The following day, the State Prison Administration Department announced that the Park Maniac, Francisco de Cisperera, had not been killed during the uprising as initially reported. Pedrino later told reporters that he wanted to murder the serial killer during the rebellion, but he had been busy looking after the hostages. His failure to carry out the murder was met with disappointment from much of the public.
这引发了人们的猜测，即杀手佩蒂已经付诸了行动兑现了他的威胁。一天后，所有人质至少都毫发无损，他们报告说，在整个事件过程中，绑架者对他们很好，佩德里诺还给他们带了食物并让他们保持舒适。第二天，州监狱管理局宣布，“公园魔头”弗朗西斯科·德·西斯佩雷拉并没有像最初报道的那样在暴动中被杀。佩德里诺后来告诉记者，他本想在暴动期间谋杀这名连环杀手，但他当时正忙着照顾人质。他未能实施谋杀让广大公众感到失望。
In the early 2000s, Brazilian authorities gathered to discuss a rare but significant problem. Article 5 of the Brazilian Constitution stated that nobody in Brazil could be sentenced for the term of their natural life in prison. The Brazilian Penal Code had been created when life expectancy in the country was 43 years and had not been updated since. The maximum sentence the code allowed an individual to serve was 30 years for all their crimes combined, regardless of the sentence given or crimes committed. Unless they died before completing their time, all prison inmates were to be released at the conclusion of the 30-year limit. Therefore, Pedrino Rodriguez Filou, who had been sentenced to a cumulative 400 years,
21世纪初，巴西当局齐聚一堂，讨论一个罕见但重大问题。巴西宪法第五条规定，巴西任何人不得被判处无期徒刑。巴西刑法典制定时，该国的平均预期寿命为43年，此后一直未作更新。无论被判何种刑期或犯下何罪，法典允许个人服刑的最高刑期，所有罪行加起来也只有30年。除非他们在刑满前死亡，否则所有监狱囚犯都将在30年期限结束时获释。因此，被判处累计400年徒刑的佩德里诺·罗德里格斯·菲略，
became eligible for parole in 2003. Although Pedrino had been convicted of 71 murders, he claimed to be responsible for at least 100. In a 2003 article titled A Monster of the System, journalist Ticardu Mondonza wrote, He likes to bolster his fame by telling other stories, many of which we cannot be sure whether they happened or not. Like many serial killers, his tales often blend reality and fantasy, and most of the corpses he is proud to have produced were never found. However, Mondonza noted that record-keeping in Brazilian prisons in the 1970s was chaotic, and authorities and journalists had to rely on witness testimony to determine what likely occurred
于2003年获得了假释资格。尽管佩德里诺被判犯有71起谋杀罪，但他声称自己至少要对100起谋杀负责。在2003年一篇名为《体制怪兽》的文章中，记者蒂卡杜·蒙东萨写道，他喜欢通过讲述其他故事来夸大自己的名气，其中许多故事我们无法确定是否真的发生过。和许多连环杀手一样，他的故事常常将现实与幻想交织在一起，而他引以为豪的绝大多数尸体也从未被找到。不过，蒙东萨指出，20世纪70年代巴西监狱的记录保存十分混乱，当局和记者不得不依靠证人证言来确定内部可能发生的情况，
inside. The article concluded, Therefore, it is probable that Pedrino has killed less than he says but more than appears in his file, in a display of inefficiency of the police and the judiciary. Pedrino had previously admitted to a reporter he would continue to kill if he was ever released, an assertion that carried no semblance of regret or remorse. He told journalist Eduardo Fostini, The things I do are good for society in my opinion. I'm killing my enemies and people who rape, who kill children, who kill family men. Do they deserve to live? Tell me. They don't. In the year leading up to his proposed release date, Pedrino was returned to the state penitentiary, where he behaved as an exemplary inmate and became the cleaning coordinator.
文章总结道，因此，佩德里诺杀的人可能比他说的少，但比他档案里显示的要多，这暴露出警察和司法系统的低效。佩德里诺此前曾向一名记者承认，如果他获释，他将继续杀人，这种说法没有丝毫的遗憾或悔意。他告诉记者爱德华多·福斯蒂尼，在我看来，我做的事对社会是有好处的。我在杀死我的敌人、强奸犯、杀害儿童的人、杀害顾家男人的人。他们配活吗？告诉我。他们不配。在他拟议释放日期的前一年，佩德里诺被送回了州立监狱，在那里他表现得像个模范囚犯，并成为了清洁协调员。
He stated that he had no enemies and didn't plan to kill anyone, unless he came across the park maniac. Pedrino looked forward to his release. Although he was entering his fifties, he still looked young and had kept fit. He planned to return to his family on the outside and earn a living working in a slaughterhouse, like he did when he was a boy, admitting that he didn't know how to do much else. He was unaware that police, prison authorities and politicians were meeting to discuss ways they could keep him locked up. At the 11th hour, a judge found an item in the criminal code that could be interpreted as stating that crimes committed after the commencement of a sentence could be considered new and separate, enabling Pedrino's sentence to be extended by another 14
他表示自己没有敌人，也不打算杀任何人，除非他遇到公园魔头。佩德里诺期盼着重获自由。尽管他已年过五十，但他看起来依然年轻，而且保持着健美的身材。他计划回到外面的家人身边，靠在屠宰场工作谋生，就像他小时候那样，他承认自己不会做太多别的事情。他并不知道警察、监狱当局和政客们正在开会商讨将他继续关押的方法。在最后关头，一名法官在刑法典中找到了一条条款，可以将其解释为在刑期开始后犯下的罪行可以被视为新的和独立的罪行，从而使佩德里诺的刑期延长了14年，
years, postponing his potential release to 2017. Although this interpretation could be challenged in higher courts, Pedrino didn't have a lawyer and remained oblivious to the plan to prevent his liberation. Journalist Ticardu Mendoza visited Pedrino the month of his proposed release and found himself in the awkward position of knowing Pedrino's fate before he did. He wrote, He believes he will be released on the 25th. In fact, this will not happen. His sentence was extended because of the crimes he committed behind bars. Pedrino could even appeal the decision, but he doesn't know about it. Pedrino eventually heard the news and managed to find someone to help him lodge an appeal. It was successful, and on April 24, 2007,
将他的潜在释放日期推迟到2017年。尽管这种解释可以在上诉法院受到性质挑战，但佩德里诺没有律师，对阻止他重获自由的计划一无所知。记者蒂卡杜·门多萨在他拟议释放的月份去探望了佩德里诺，却发现自己处于一个尴尬的境地：他比佩德里诺本人更早知道了对方的命运。他写道，他相信自己将在25号获释。事实上，这不会发生。他的刑期因他在狱中犯下的罪行而延长了。佩德里诺甚至可以对这一决定提出上诉，但他对此一无所知。佩德里诺最终听到了这个消息，并设法找到人帮他提起上诉。上诉成功了，2007年4月24日，
Pedrino Rodrigues Filou was released from prison after serving 34 years, four more than the current law admitted. The Brazilian prison system didn't provide any sort of re-socialization program, and at least 70% of released prisoners went on to re-offend. In addition, former inmates were not monitored following their discharge, leaving Pedrino to his own devices. He moved into a pink cottage in a remote area of the country to live a quiet life with his new pet Labrador. He attended church in a small village nearby and worked as a caretaker on a farm, with his neighbour describing him to reporters as a hard-working, serious, and religious man. Authorities were eager to re-arrest Pedrino from the moment he was released,
佩德里诺·罗德里格斯·菲略在服刑34年后获释，比当时的法律所允许的刑期多出了四年。巴西监狱系统没有提供任何形式的重新社会化计划，至少有70%的获释囚犯会再次犯罪。此外，前囚犯在刑满释放后不会受到监控，这让佩德里诺处于无人监管的状态。他搬进了该国偏远地区的一栋粉红色小屋，与他的新宠物拉布拉多犬过着安静的生活。他在附近的一个小村庄做礼拜，并在一个农场担任看护，他的邻居向记者描述他是一个勤劳、严肃而虔诚的人。当局从他获释的那一刻起就渴望重新逮捕佩德里诺，
but didn't know where to find him. After an anonymous tip-off to the Civil Police Division of Criminal Investigations, he was tracked down to a farmhouse in Cambuyu in Brazil's south. On the morning of September 15, 2011, he was arrested and charged in relation to six riots that occurred during his incarceration, including the deprivation of liberty of a prison officer. Pedrino was also in possession of a loaded 38-caliber revolver, violating the terms of his release and earning him another charge. He didn't resist, entrusting his dog to his neighbour as he was led away. Dozens of reporters were waiting at the police station. One asked, Do you think you've already paid for your crimes? Pedrino nodded and replied,
但不知道去哪里找他。在接到向民警局犯罪调查部门提供的匿名举报后，他被追踪到巴西南部坎布尤的一个农场。2011年9月15日上午，他被捕并被指控与他服刑期间发生的六次骚动有关，包括剥夺一名狱警的人身自由。佩德里诺还持有上膛的38口径左轮手枪，违反了假释条款，并为他招致了另一项指控。他没有反抗，在被带走时将他的狗托付给了邻居。数十名记者在警察局外等候。其中一人问，你觉得你已经为你的罪行赎罪了吗？佩德里诺点点头回答说，
I've paid for my crimes. He fell back into his familiar prison routine of working out, reading, and fostering his celebrity status. Fan mail arrived constantly and he received more visitors than ever, including news reporters, filmmakers, and authors who wanted to document his life. He was compared to fictional serial killer Dexter Morgan from the television series Dexter, who regarded himself a vigilante dispensing justice where the system had failed to do so. In a 2012 prison interview, Pedrino told journalist Marcelo Hazend he hadn't killed anyone he thought he shouldn't have, saying that he didn't believe in regrets. On December 6, 2017, six years after his second arrest, Pedrino was once again released.
我已经为我的罪行赎罪了。他重新陷入了他熟悉的监狱生活日常：锻炼、阅读，并培养他的名人地位。粉丝来信源源不断，他接待的访客比以往任何时候都多，包括新闻记者、电影制作人和想要记录他一生的作家。他被拿来与电视剧《嗜血法官》中的虚构连环杀手德克斯特·摩根作比较，后者认为自己是在体制失效的地方伸张正义的私刑执行者。在2012年的一次监狱采访中，佩德里诺告诉记者马塞洛·哈森德，他没有杀过任何他认为不该杀的人，并表示他不相信后悔。2017年12月6日，在他第二次被捕六年之后，佩德里诺再次获释。
At 64 years old, he still looked youthful, due in part to a strict fitness regime that started every morning at 4am. Though he wasn't convicted of any murders during his second incarceration, in an interview with journalist Roberto Cabrini for the TV show Connects Our Reporter, Pedrino said the last murder he carried out was, quote, about five years ago. He clarified that it wasn't committed in prison, and when pressed further, he refused to discuss the matter, saying, it's kind of complicated. Pedrino told Cabrini he would not kill again unless someone were to harm his family. He maintained a close relationship with one of his sisters and her family, and often joined
64岁的他依然显得很年轻，这部分归功于他严格的健身习惯，每天早上4点开始。虽然他在第二次服刑期间没有被判犯有任何谋杀罪，但在接受电视节目《联系我们的记者》主持人罗伯托·卡布里尼采访时，佩德里诺表示他实施的最后一次谋杀是，引述，“大约五年前”。他澄清说这不是在监狱里犯下的，当被进一步追问时，他拒绝讨论此事，并说，这有点复杂。佩德里诺告诉卡布里尼，除非有人伤害他的家人，否则他不会再杀人。他与其中一个姐姐及其家人保持着密切的关系，并经常加入他们的晚餐。
them for dinner. He also attended church regularly, certain that God had forgiven him for his sins, and expressed the desire to marry and have a son and a daughter. But he still had enemies, detailing an incident that occurred in Santa Catarina where he was almost killed but managed to escape when his opponents left to get reinforcements. He claimed he did not seek revenge. Pedrino has since embraced social media, where his story has taken on a life of its own. He has been dubbed the Dexter serial killer, and his admirers believe he rid the world of evil and protected those unable to protect themselves. In Brazil, less than 10% of murders are solved, and many Brazilians think Pedrino was the vigilante they needed. He has amassed
他还定期去教堂，确信上帝已经原谅了他的罪过，并表达了结婚并生一个儿子和一个女儿的愿望。但他仍然有敌人，他详细讲述了在圣卡塔琳娜州发生的一次事件，当时他险些被杀，但在对手离开去寻找增援时设法逃脱了。他声称自己没有寻求复仇。此后，佩德里诺拥抱了社交媒体，他的故事在那里焕发出了新的生命。他被冠以“德克斯特连环杀手”的称号，他的崇拜者认为他为世界清除了邪恶，并保护了那些无法保护自己的人。在巴西，不到10%的谋杀案能被侦破，许多巴西人认为佩德里诺正是他们需要的私刑执行者。他在Facebook上积累了
two and a half thousand friends on Facebook where he posts motivational quotes, videos demonstrating his culinary skills, and pictures of new tattoos covering the ones from his past. Maria's name has been covered with a feather, which Pedrino explained. I erased it because she no longer exists, she is no more. His most infamous tattoo, which read, I kill for pleasure, is replaced with an image of a scorpion, one that read, revenge, now says, love. Pedrino has written and released the first part of his autobiography, Pedrino Matador. Right from the start, he appears to mix fact and fiction, falsely claiming to be born at the stroke of midnight on October 30 as if to portray himself
两千五百个好友，他在那里发布励志名言、展示厨艺的视频，以及覆盖过去纹身的新纹身照片。玛丽亚的名字被一片羽毛覆盖，佩德里诺对此解释说，我把它抹掉了，因为她已经不复存在了，她不在了。他最臭名昭著的纹身上写着“我为快乐而杀戮”，现在被一只蝎子的图像所取代，而写着“复仇”的那个现在则写着“爱”。佩德里诺已经写并出版了他的自传的第一部分《杀手佩德里诺》。从一开始，他就似乎将事实与虚构混为一谈，虚假地声称自己出生于10月30日的午夜，仿佛要把自己塑造成某种万圣节的预兆。
as some sort of Halloween omen. He is an unreliable narrator, confusing his stories from one telling to another. He is prone to exaggeration and boasts of incidents and crimes that may or may not have happened. The inconsistencies only seem to fuel his legendary status in Brazilian folklore. A rap song has been written about him, he is available for motivational talks and interviews, and is currently working on a documentary with director Bruno Santana. He now claims he wants to leave Pedrino Matador, killer Petey behind, telling reporter William Cardozo, I don't want to be known by that name anymore. But the title has become his brand. His YouTube channel, which has 83,000 subscribers and over five and a half million views,
他是一个不可靠的叙述者，在转述时常常把他的故事搞混。他倾向于夸大其词，吹嘘那些可能发生也可能没有发生的事件和罪行。这些不一致之处似乎只会助长他在巴西民间传说中的传奇色彩。一首关于他的说唱歌曲被创作出来，他可以接受励志演讲和采访，目前正与导演布鲁诺·桑塔纳合作拍摄一部纪录片。他现在声称他想抛下《杀手佩德里诺》这个身份，他告诉记者威廉·卡多佐，我不想再用那个名字为人所知了。但这个头衔已经成了他的品牌。他的YouTube频道拥有83,000名订阅者和超过五百五十万次的观看量，
is called Pedrino X Matador, and states, In this channel, you will know and follow the life of the greatest serial killer in Brazil. Pedrino Matador was sentenced to the largest penalty ever seen in Brazil. He beat the record for survival in jail and beat the record time arrested. There had never been another detainee that spent so much time behind bars. The idea for this channel came from his friend Pablo Silva and is intended to show the crime does not pay. He often uploads several videos a day and doubles in live streaming. The videos are produced by his friend, 30-year-old Pablo Silva, and feature messages from Pedrino about crime and God. Archive footage of old interviews reports on the crimes he is morally
名叫“佩德里诺X杀手”，上面写着，在这个频道里，你将了解并关注巴西最伟大的连环杀手的生平。杀手佩德里诺被判处了巴西有史以来最重的刑罚。他打破了在狱中生存的纪录，也打破了被捕时间的纪录。从来没有第二个囚犯在铁窗后度过如此长的时间。这个频道的想法来自他的朋友巴勃罗·席尔瓦，旨在表明犯罪没有好下场。他经常一天上传几个视频，并且兼职进行直播。这些视频由他30岁的朋友巴勃罗·席尔瓦制作，其中包含佩德里诺关于犯罪和上帝的信息。
opposed to, publicity for his book, and snippets of his day-to-day life. He shares lessons for young people about the dangers of crime, warning them that illicit drugs and activities such as vandalism, skateboarding, disrespecting elders, and lying to parents are all against his code of conduct. A celebrity in his hometown, when out in public, he is often stopped by police who want to shake his hand and fans requesting a selfie. Pedrino claims he craves a quiet life, living on a farm with a dog surrounded by trees and animals. He says he no longer dreams about the men he is killed and believes he is living proof that psychopaths can be rehabilitated. In 2019, he told Roberto Cabrini for The Connect's Hour reporter,
过去采访的档案片段记录了他所反对的犯罪行为、其书本的宣传以及他日常生活的一些片段。他与年轻人分享关于犯罪危险的教训，警告他们非法药物以及诸如恶意破坏、滑板、不尊重长辈和对父母撒谎等活动都违背了他的行为准则。作为家乡的名人，当他出现在公共场合时，经常会有想跟他握手的警察和要求自拍的粉丝拦住他。佩德里诺声称他渴望过上平静的生活，与一条狗住在一个四周环绕着树木和动物的农场里。他说他不再梦见被他杀死的人，并相信自己是精神病患者可以被改造的活生生的证据。2019年，他告诉《联系我们的记者》的罗伯托·卡布里尼，
In this world where we are now, I'm not taking anyone's life. I'm cured. The hour-long interview tried to find some degree of humanity and repentance in Pedrino, but he remained emotionless throughout. He remarked, I don't regret it because the people I killed weren't worth a shit. The people I murdered weren't even worth the food they ate. If I didn't kill them, they would kill me. They would kill other people who didn't deserve to die. Cabrini asked, Do you sometimes feel like a temptation, a will to kill, to which Kilopidi replied, Yes, but it fades away. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在这个我们如今身处的世界里，我没有剥夺任何人的生命。我已经痊愈了。这个长达一小时的采访试图在佩德里诺身上找到某种程度的人性和忏悔，但他始终面无表情。他评论说，我不后悔，因为我杀的人连狗屁都不如。我谋杀的人甚至不配吃他们吃过的食物。如果我不杀了他们，他们就会杀了我。他们会杀害其他不该死的人。卡布里尼问，你有时会感到一种诱惑、一种杀人的冲动吗？杀手佩蒂回答说，是的，但它会消逝。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。